boulevard podcast
special guest
compton zone
the homie life is here see what it is we
in this thing man what's happening
well listen man you're obviously uh been
around for a very long time man some
might call you a uh uh la uh legend in
these streets man yeah yeah you already
know you've been uh
how long have you been active as a
rapper man
[ __ ] man since i came off the wall to be
honest
and you obviously you got the og black
wall street tat so what year what year
did you actually like sign with black
wall street [ __ ] i got that tattoo when
i was like 14. my mama didn't even want
me to get the mug i just went and got it
uh
that's about time i so 14 i think that
was like what what what year was that
like 2000 and what six or something like
oh 506.05 yeah
so like
that's when i first started like really
you feel me rocking with black wall
street
getting to it yes sir and you've been
killing it independently um you've been
dropping a lot of videos a lot of music
um just kind of catch people up what's
going on with you currently before we
have you spit these bars [ __ ] right now
you feel me i'm um
in the middle of dropping a project with
scott starch you feel me got a ep got
going with him
and um after that we gonna drop a
mixtape uh
seven beats seven places so it's like
i'm gonna do seven beats
seven different locations you feel me
and that's basically the rollout that i
got going right now entire sky storage
produced ep yep that's huge man hell
yeah [ __ ] crack too who can smoke more
you or him
[ __ ] scott stars that [ __ ] smokes he
smokes food so for sure so he be i think
it was in there off some wax some off
yeah i'm like god damn yeah he's a pro
man that [ __ ] smokes for sure he is a
pro and he'll hit you he'll hit the
blunt and then he'll go outside and take
down the damn marlboro you know what i'm
saying [ __ ] intense for sure but look
let's get to it man let everybody know
where's your social media all that [ __ ]
before you hit this beat call me life
two eyes man c-a-l-l
m-e-l-i-i-f-e call me life on twitter
instagram all that good [ __ ] go follow
let's get to it man take taco all that
beat by
sdot my [ __ ] stop put me on this beach
you hear what i'm saying look
look like been bragging since [ __ ]
trapped on the motorolas the coldest
oldest bus through the pack [ __ ] close
your nose i put the coast up on my back
she gave me scoliosis it got hot up in
the kitchen still a [ __ ] flow dakotas i
know i'm chose to blow up god give his
biggest battles to his toughest soldiers
hold up hold that he told but he got
dough and [ __ ] like so what that's how
i go around this [ __ ] while i can't
show him no love hey hey you know i'm
the truth bro [ __ ] juice i'm uno big
blood like glucose r.i.p
they tried to lock me out the game but
still i found the loopholes the truth
shows up in the puddin bro i am too cold
these [ __ ] acting like they really
with that letting the two blow boy you
wouldn't bust a grape out here you
[ __ ] fruit bowl i up my nose for that
reason get close and the strap squeeze
and it's that season [ __ ] leave it's
top leaking [ __ ] know my thesis [ __ ]
piecing up won't the whole thing flow
flames own these [ __ ] next like a rope
chain grinding all my life i ain't got
no shame no sir on the road to richard
so long i need a chauffeur [ __ ] like
life when he rap we just hope he go
first [ __ ] like he can rap a long time
[ __ ] with no curse word on him i keep
that [ __ ] on me call it a turd on me
[ __ ] like damn he from captain not the
suburbs homie hell nah my shell's tall
[ __ ] like shack toe back though they
try to do that when you get cash flow
back flow duffled up [ __ ] can't [ __ ]
with us up is up down this down we gon
give em upper cups around the town [ __ ]
i'm feeling like i was eric wright every
night shoveling stove gotta keep my
barrel tight right up on the side of me
born and raised up in poverty used to
wear all them wallace these [ __ ] know
where my policy is
get money [ __ ] hoes touch doe [ __ ]
know me [ __ ] i be out cut throat miss
my [ __ ] slim fo
[ __ ] ask my dog and i'm freestyling off
the top
listen
there we are that's that's it go follow
my guy my dog is your ig one more time
call me like two hours man [ __ ] with the
guys you feel me we in here dropping big
spillers in and out just like that all
day [ __ ] one take jake you know yeah
i'm going on [ __ ]
hey i know you just watched a brand new
freestyle presented to you by our good
folks at lrg don't forget if you go to
lrg right now the website will be right
there broom l dash r dash g.com
use the promo code bootleg and you'll
get 30 off your order that's
l-r-g.com you'll see it right down there
save 30 off your order by putting in
that promo code bootleg and shout out to
lrg we got another freestyle coming next
week